[Musique]
nicolas et pimprenelle souhaiter bonne
nuit au petit pinocchio voulait devenir
un vrai petit garçon et guignol fait
toujours vivre les spectacles pour
enfants toutes ces marionnettes se sont
installés dans les 400 m² de salles
d'exposition de l'hôtel de ville de la
celle-saint-cloud première actes elle
vous raconte leur histoire la marine
actuellement probablement a dû naître un
jour dans une caverne parce qu'un petit
enfant a pris un bâton et un un petit
caillou et qu'il les a mis en rapport et
qu'il a fait parler d'eux sort ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est le premier art qui
avait vu le jour bien avant la sculpture
bien avant le théâtre vient d'avoir la
peinture la marionnette a ouvert la voie
en particulier de courant dramatique
passionné de la marionnette marc andrey
est une véritable encyclopédie de l'art
du castelet de la première la
marionnettes à tringles à la marionnette
à gaine
il expose une bonne partie de sa
collection lorsque le jeu est terminé on
posa marionnettes on en prend
éventuellement une autre elle fait
toujours rentrer cour jardin dans les
mêmes conditions que cau théâtre
deuxième acte l'époque contemporaine et
les différentes techniques de
fabrication du bois au polystyrène
nadine de la noaa s'est formé auprès des
plus grands artisans pour apprendre tout
leur secret est un hobby dont elle fait
son métier après un licenciement
économique
quand mes ex collègues m'ont vu
commencer à fabriquer des marionnettes
se sont dit c'est une lubie
quinze ans après vous voyez pas du tout
ça occupe l'intégralité de mes journées
aujourd'hui mon travail est reconnu
elle dédie l'exposition à vladimir
sakharov inventeur de la marionnette à
poigne et récemment décédé qui lui avait
enseigné toutes les précisions de son
travail de plasticienne elle a même cédé
à la tentation de marionnettistes et
fait vivre l'une de ses créations
madame lemieux sa fille je serais très
heureuse devons rencontrer
s'anime voir les 200 marionnettes sont
présente jusqu'au 14 avril
nadine delannoy et marc-andré
partageront leur passion lors de visites
animées les dimanches 31 mars et le 14
avril
[Musique]